okay so we have a look at it together
I've seen a few answers most of them are
in the general right direction okay but
they're missing a few things let's have
a look at together now this is one
example where remember I told you you've
got these two approaches right but this
is kind of a crutch it's not a good way
to do it it's not effective and this is
a prime example of why okay it really
lets you down in fact do you visually
far more reliable okay let's think about
what happens when you do this and you
just you know machine it down okay so
this is going to be 2x plus 3 or square
right okay so you can very simply as a
perfect square so it's not hard to just
you're going to get 4x squared plus 12x
plus 9 ya happy okay now you can go
through that you can work out any of the
features that you need if you had just
given been given this as a quadratic
function okay but boy is that
time-consuming right let me show you a
better way let's think about this you've
got here on this graph some very
important points right we're thinking
about taking these values right these
are these vertical values are our Y
values and then squaring it right so for
example the first thing you should see
is this point here yeah what's the Y
value for this point zero right and zero
squared is zero right
so a few of you have drawn your graph
and you know it's going to be a parabola
you expected that but you've drawn it
sort of off over here okay and your
intersection point your route is
somewhere to the left of negative one
and a half right well if you think about
it visually zero squared must be zero so
I'm done there right okay next thing the
next most obvious point after the
x-intercept is the y-intercept right now
you could go up to this square it and
you're like oh look there's my constant
but come on
no matter visually it's a much easier
way to know that it's nine why is it
nine because this is your one day right
and you square that and off you go
okay now unfortunately that's not on the
UM the it's the scale is too small but
you'd be somewhere up here okay so you
know you're going to skyrocket up okay
now before I draw that in there's one
other important point that no one so far
has gotten right and I'll admit like I
just want to see how you'd go remember
we started by looking at this point
right the reason I chose this point is
because 0 when it comes to squaring 0 is
an important number actually 0 is always
an important as you'll see there's one
other number that's really important
when you square it right that has very
predictable behavior 0 when you square
it it becomes itself there's one other
number that you can square and it'll
become itself that number is 1 ok so
that should mean that well I actually
can tell where one's going to be it's
going to be about thing right so that
exact spot f of X equal 1 f of X is
equal to 1 therefore f of X all squared
should also be equal to 1 so therefore
my original graph and the square of my
original graph should intersect right
there ok and most people instinctively
when they draw their parabola right it
kind of you've got a stationary point
there and so it sort of collided
here somewhere up there right but you
can see this is an important point you
must collide with them and on my graph
you can see if I'm going to get up to 9
by there it's got to be pretty steep so
that's hard to do I've given you very
small graphs and features hard to
identify when I draw it
right so it makes the problem a bit hard
to see I'm gonna reflect it across right
well that's not very symmetrical you can
do better than that
but I will actually go to the effort of
labeling at that point okay
this point is obvious cuz it's on the
axis right but I'll say I know where
this is right I know that that's you
know I'm gonna draw a line across to one
and show that it's equal there but
that's where the intersection point is
that's a critical value okay now let's
do this one all together I'm going to
continue on the importance of zero and
one it's not just important when you
square okay so let's have a look at this
back and we walk through him together
if I have my original function and then
I take its reciprocal okay let's think
about these critical values again what
happens when the original function is
zero what's the reciprocal of zero okay
so infinities are common air time but it
actually doesn't make sense it doesn't
work if you try and do your math of it
it doesn't work in fact one over zero
what is your it's undefined okay it's
not just undefined it can't be defined
right so for the graph what that means
is the graph can't exist at that point
right I can't say oh it's gonna be here
or there or somewhere everywhere even it
can't be anywhere on this so for this x
value right I'm gonna get an asymptote
which of course if you had gone to the
effort of doing this algebraically and
say well this is 1 over 2x plus 3
you'd instinctively know rational
functions are going to end up with
asymptotes vertical asymptotes like this
so now I've got one you don't even need
to go through this you don't even
necessarily know what that value is but
that's gonna give you a vertical
asymptote all right now we said zeros
important one's also important why would
one be important on a graph like this
we're taking reciprocals are we right so
if f of X is equal to one then one on f
of X is also equal to one so one is its
own reciprocal right now remember what
we saw over here if the original graph
and our transformed graph have the same
value that means they intersect at that
point okay
so in fact what I'm gonna do and this is
kind of a general helpful way when you
get graphs like this or this or this as
you'll see is I'm going to draw y equals
one onto my graph okay I'm gonna draw y
equals one on there if that's one right
and wherever it is intersecting with my
original graph which happens to be there
okay I know my new function is going to
pass through there it's gonna intersect
with the original okay now we had a look
here zero when you square it gives you
zero one when you square it gives you
one those are our important points okay
over here when you take the reciprocal
right zero is implant what is important
because it gives you the reciprocal of 1
is 1 there's another number
that is its own reciprocal hmm I think
there's another number and the number is
anyone thinking if one very good because
of course one on negative one is
negative one okay
so not only am I gonna draw in y equals
one a show label that there's y equals
one I'm going to drop in Y it was
negative one
okay because wherever that intersects
with my original graph which happens to
be there my new guy's gonna pass through
that okay
so this is looking good we've got a
whole bunch of features under two points
the graph is faster I know I've got this
asymptote here this vertical asymptote
and now I want to think about how the
graph is behaving towards its
extremities because that'll tell me
where I need to go from here like here
I'm gonna approach that asymptote here
I'm gonna approach this asymptote but I
want to know what's happening outside
now this is where the a Drake help
approach does kind of help you look at
this you know what this looks like right
when X approaches infinity what is
whatever 2x plus 3 doing yeah very good
next person infinity right 1 over 2x
plus 3 is approaching 0 because the
denominator is getting enormous so the
whole numbers becoming first of all okay
and you can replay the same kind of
scenario over I'm sorry over here on the
left hand side as X approaches large
negative values it's still approaching 0
so I don't just have a vertical
asymptote I have a horizontal asymptote
on the x-axis okay there we go so
there's my and that's all the
information I need to draw this thing
because it's a hyperbola you're any new
that I just need to make sure it passes
through these critical points that I've
already mentioned
by the way having drawn this you can see
that whoa that looks like it's important
right but you don't need to do much
fancy work with the numbers to know what
that value is equal to you can look at
it visually you can say look my original
value is three so this is the reciprocal
of three it's just a third which is
exactly what it looks like if you draw
it reasonably accurately